ready for this we were talking about
like yeah he's not going to pick him
there's no way and he does
so this should be talking up a storm
and yeah for sure because bokoram does
have the tools just to keep thing at bay
he could just poke him out his long
reaching limbs is standing three
uh especially if if things backs against
the wall like again uh nobody's gonna
have to guess and he's gonna have to be
very careful with those charge uh
charged up attack
yeah one of the things we got a note too
about pokemon if you guys aren't
familiar with them he does not really
have a good sidestep probably one of the
worst side steps in the game if not the
worst however his offensive capability
and his ability to kind of mix up and
pressure the opponent is one of the best
in the game and that's really what keeps
him as a contender
yeah and again nobody just wanting to
keep him at bay here now the pokes are
coming out goes for the low and secures
that first round
here we go nice wall standing
and you we know that double is so good
with the while standing attacks and that
while 73 was just again proof of it
we'll go to the well once again with
opportunity presents itself but let's
see double though oh gets the crumple
and now gets the round
yeah this character can hurt
oh yeah
oh jab there tries to keep his opponent
at bay
uh-huh guaranteed down four after that
whoa what a big four one plus two
yo big characters eat it
yeah exactly yeah
oh but yeah he could just hell sweep his
way out of it tags on a little more
those lows pushing to the center of the
stage
double now yeah able to get himself out
of that really tough spot but nobody
again trying to press on the offense
just a little bit grant some rage oh it
didn't pull the trigger on two hit
launch
whoa
oh he's going to do the rage art he
should be able to get this
[Music]
wow that was looking like it was going
in nobody's favor but yeah leave it at
the double to pull off a comeback just
like that
great patience on double side
all right here we go two rounds to one
double right now showing that his pick
paid off he goes for the punch reversal
gets him with the kicks
and the wall here is in play
how how is nobody going to deal with
this what is he going to do okay
able to get out of that thunder i get
that jet kick
you know
sidewall though
we've seen him make comebacks before can
he do it once again didn't pull the
trigger on the forward four or four oh
able to float him he ran in he jabs him
yeah he ran into
downstairs though he doesn't need it
doesn't need it final round here match
number one
kenpo start okay nice punish there
oh the death mills now followed up to
the wall combo tries to switch sides but
no patience on double side wakes up hell
sweeps and follows it up he's playing
like a mashima
oh he caught him with the jet
oh my god this might be it oh no the
wall wasn't there
dang that was close yeah
back and forth you try to chase him down
so i got i have this thought in my mind
right you know uh obviously he was still
close it was still close but however the
problem being just the matchup with
bakum bakumram in general is having to
battle with him and you could tell
nobody was much more limited in how he
was able to approach the matchup because
of certain things
i have a feeling if he is going to
switch
which he might
the only switch he would make is not to
dragon off but to steve because steve is
one of those characters that can kind of
help restrict what he's going up against
with [ __ ] rob so
that's that's my my thinking or my line
of thinking here but then again i'm not
one of these pro players i'm just i'm
just a guy that wears shades and does
commentary
we're just on the mic we're like the
professional fans we're just here to
watch the matches and get hyped but i
agree with you though if he chooses that
this matchup isn't for him even though
it did get to that final round i think
steve is the pick to go for we've seen
how his steve is able to just cancel out
those options and just just be wary of
the approach so uh that back one is
constantly a threat he knows how to get
in um and he could duck those those high
jet kicks but seems like he's about
ready for um more of the [ __ ] rom of
double so he is still sticking it out
with fang but changing it up going in a
smaller stage dragon's nest so this
could as you would say a double-edged
sword because fakamram shines when he's
pressing you against the wall
oh yeah he has so many options and we're
not just talking about wall carry but
his ability to pressure out the wall his
guard crush moves but also certain
things like his wall rising one two able
to splat from so far away he he
definitely has great advantages in
smaller stages
still fighting at the center of the
stage but we see that nobody's still
undeterred here still
trying to work his offense but yeah
double just getting the pokes and the
two hit launch
and we're gonna see the wall too
great stuff what a good first opening
round here for double again continuing
his lead
oh he's letting grip
uh-oh
head nice counter hits
on him
um
looking really good
trying to go for the punch tsubaki nice
movement from nobi okay
back and forth they go
oh just pressuring with that jet kick
it's so scary when it's blocked still
i mean it's like pretty much like an
electric goddess the way it is on block
it's so crazy
it's so intimidating yeah just like yeah
you better watch out for this
try ducking it went for the hop kick
excellent stuff that was wild
oh the big boy combo too
[Music]
nice challenge
yeah nobody taking that third round
one more to tie things up it's so far so
good on novi's side okay
good early sequence for novi
nice interrupt here nobody looking
really really good here in match number
two
the second hit you got to watch out for
it
you can't rest on double you saw he's
very capable of those comebacks oh but i
spoke bro nice hot pick from no beside
the adjustment
the side step and pulling out that
clutch hop kick it really says a lot for
the matchup and how he studied for it oh
that was that was brutal so now tied up
one a piece where we're going to see
more of the same i can't see him
switching from broken rum here bakaram
has been working out for him in in quite
a good way it just it didn't work out
for him at the very end he knows now
that nobody knows the certain holes that
he can exploit in the matchup
no it's uh it's it's double's job to
adjust accordingly yeah i do agree that
maybe we don't have to he doesn't have
to think about switching just yet
uh this still is a brace to three so
yeah maybe like saving up that lydia but
i think he's invested too much time and
it depends on how the next match goes if
it goes like sort of even i mean i still
think he could just rock with focaram
the whole way
but yeah um i would have to say his
[ __ ] mom is very effective
oh yeah because it's totally forcing
nobody to play outside of the box play a
different style again you know he can't
take the same liberties that he would
take normally going into a matchup and i
think that's one of the strengths when
you use a a crazy character uh like
lydia like pokemon or like leroy is you
force your opponent to play another way
and that's really i think one of the the
the biggest strengths of these
characters that maybe most people don't
highlight anyways tied up in matches
here one a piece
and i like that you mentioned that he
had to play like outside the box he had
to really create those openings those
micro steps and for him to be able to
capitalize on the openings that focus on
presents and being very careful and
making his approach
so nobody is still doing the same of the
previous round but
it just could change with a big jet kick
so
let's see how double will handle this uh
this thing
oh nobody doing such a great job right
now gets the pickup
okay nobody's still on fire gets the
first round
let's see
hey gets the screw early on double
oh not able capitalize nice block on the
low rising three and no be
able to capitalize
and gain so much damage look at that
life already gone follow it up
oh he caught up right with the wall
yeah the wall messed up everything it
ruined it
mm-hmm
he just needs one more you're gonna deal
with the no are you gonna do with the
blue shoulder what are you gonna do
because i can chip them to death too
try to risk it there but yeah nobody so
far making a huge statement getting two
rounds straight
doubles gonna have to act look at that
cancel out that charged up punch goes
for the hop kick instead
yep nobody is comfortable comfortable
now in this matchup
oh
he's chopping away at the legs this is
what he does
oh what a whiff punish there no be
locked and loaded
jet kick just for uh just some
compression yep
oh oh it's him out of the back turn a
nice escape there from nobi followed it
up
oh my god oh that's gonna whip funny
no
wow
he's gonna take the third round double
what a call out there in the rage art
great start for nobi so far but we've
seen how double again falconrom can hit
like a truck so you have to be very
careful
tagging the legs
still not going for anything too crazy
oh we almost caught him there
look at the pressure the three plus four
yeah he's really swinging big okay
nice escape from nobi
grant's double some rage away from oh
caught him coming in but no he's gonna
block that
and there's that shoulder you were
talking about mark
nobi up two to one
quite the change here
uh i gotta say nobody's doing such a
great job of kind of spacing out against
ram
uh
doubles in trouble double has to figure
out
what he's going to do here in this match
whether it's going to be changing
characters or starting to rely on
different moves to really open up his
offense i don't know what he's going to
do
yeah you just saw the the defense on
nobody's side like you know he was
trying to threaten with that uh the back
forward for the the jet kick we saw that
he was trying to just open him up with
pokes but yeah you know he did tag him
just a little bit but the bigger swings
really went on nobody's favor and he was
able to yes i think it was the second
round or the third round he was able to
just get wall-to-wall combos so now as
you said double
he's in deep waters now he's gonna have
to think about a game plan to try and
counter nobi because uh nobi has his
number as we speak so
could it you think it would be involve a
character switch or just a change of
play styles with fakamram
i think it's hard to tell i mean i feel
like ifakuram is working but it's not
working the way he wants it was working
especially well at the start of the set
but maybe it's time for a change it is
it is there we go mm-hmm
yep
getting there right in the head going
with the lydia now this is gonna be
quite tough because nobody is
running with a full head of steam double
like made the [ __ ] rum work just a
little bit
it is two to one he's gonna have to yeah
sweep nobody with this lydia
very important because he is stuck with
lydia for the duration of the set now
and he has two matches that he needs to
win
so far so good the walk and now just all
from chip that all from pokes
no b okay afford two
oh no
nobody gets punished there and double
yep
lydia so far so good
[Music]
that was a great hop kick oh man
mm-hmm here we go has the wall is gonna
do a lot of damage
all right still control
yeah that was insane what a read there
able to just get away from the
uh that option from double yeah that's
that's something double has to worry
about those kenpo steps tried to pick
him up and fail to do so now double
okay going low this time but the wake up
from nobi
clipping him guaranteeing some wall
again huge lively night slow parry
looking to close things out one more hit
can do it
oh
he still gets a crumple
um
i mean that's fortunate and unfortunate
at the same time
true oh
yeah he was able to capitalize a little
bit but now
nobody one more round away from heading
to grand finals can he do it double
though
i want to keep him here in the losers
there we go offense coming out of double
what does he do oh
political storm he went for the punish
but not able to get it still got the
last hit is double going to tie it up on
rounds here
can he do it
oh my god he was able to open him up
he did against the wall oh there we go
final round double staying alive
too many jabs there got greedy with it
very very important round the most
important round of the set so far
will double be able to stay alive here
whoa
things are looking good
one more mix-up could do it
oh but man nobody finding his opening
it's gonna be so important here double
has to be very careful
nobody spends the rage oh interrupt him
before he could go
and nobody
wow able to three one double sending him
out of here and now it is gonna be nobee
versus again in grand
yeah finals get their they get the the
the chance to fight again together but
man i gotta say looking at all the
matches and all of the stuff that we saw
there that pressure there from fenway at
the very end was just too much for
double to handle that was crazy
it was